[Music]
everyone thanks for coming
my name is Chad I'm a product manager on
bigquery and thanks for spending the
next hour of your lives with us we're
gonna
I've got joined by a couple colleagues
here and we're gonna spend the next
roughly 40 45 minutes going through
firebase analytics the firebase
analytics schema and showing you some
really slick sequel tricks to be able to
deal with the schema so how many folks
here like primarily firebase analytics
people cool how many people here like
primarily sequel analytics folks okay
this talk is this talk is for you and
it's a 300 level talk so we're gonna be
swapping between demos and lots of
sequel code and back and forth between
that and couple slides and there's very
little market texture in this talk right
yeah that generally gets a shout out all
right so here's what we're gonna do with
the session we're gonna go through the
schema in detail it's a highly nested
and repeated schema and so if you don't
know the tricks about working with that
it can be a little bit daunting but
hopefully at the end of this session you
will have completely demystified it
we're going to go through a whole bunch
of queries that are outside the scope of
the standard fire-based analytics
dashboard and then covered the sequel
techniques and then at the end Felipe
Hoffa is going to go through how to take
the firebase analytics template that's
available to everybody and then
customize it with whatever query you
want and he'll do an example from the
session here all right so your your
presenters are me I'm on bigquery Eugene
Gerard is product manager for firebase
and then Felipe Hoffa literally if you
type mr. big query into Google you get
him all righty I won't spend a ton of
time on these kind of introductory
slides but for the benefit of those
watching on YouTube and for those who
don't know we'll just do a little bit of
high-level stuff so Google Analytics for
firebase is the agent by
which we collect data that comes from
your app do some aggregates and then
produce the stats that you can then
render inside the template or wherever
you want but you have a question like
one of the problems that folks encounter
here is what if you get to a question
that's not contained now in that
template or what's what if you get to a
question that's kind of outside what
firebase produces out of the box like
what happens if you want something
that's not on this dashboard and that
one is enter bigquery so bigquery is
google cloud platforms enterprise data
warehouse it's where it's where big data
comes and lives and thrives it goes
super fast over super big amounts of
data it also goes really fast over
smaller amounts of data so firebase in
the analyst from you know from folks
working over gigabytes to folks working
over petabytes works equally well for
both use cases a couple details here
it's serverless which means you don't
have to worry about provisioning
resources you just pipe your data in and
bring your workloads write your queries
and go for it so you don't have to spin
up nodes we take care of all of that in
the background for you this one is the
only call a market Tector slide and I
actually think this is the most useful
most useful market xers slide that we
have because GCP has over one
now the phones come out right
GCP has over a hundred products right
now so there are over a hundred little
blue hexagons and I don't know about you
all but I can get a little bit confused
when I'm trying to interpret what these
icons mean so I wanted to put this up
here to show you kind of the spectrum of
storage and data based products that we
have and where bigquery sits so bigquery
is over here as the enterprise data
warehouse so it behaves somewhat like a
relational database except you can go
arbitrarily big really good for
analytics really good for reporting
really good for dashboarding so yeah the
old story was this new story is this and
you can ask it kind of any question you
want you don't have to do indexes you
don't have to pre aggregate you can
you full table scans on whatever
question you want cool so with that
we're gonna get into the next part of
the talk so Eugene is gonna come up and
he's going to talk about a little bit
about sequel and then go through the
schema all right tag you're it we're
gonna be talking about sequel here and
and the important thing about sequel is
that you got to know your data if you're
gonna make use of it well thank you so
when I started learning sequel way back
in University I ran a lot of queries
that kind of look like this where you'd
select some stuff from a bunch of rows
and columns and you'd do a select
statement that said which column which
rows you were actually interested in and
then you'd end up with something down at
the bottom that kind of showed you what
you were looking at the the thing there
is that it was always kind of a very
grid like look you have all these rows
and columns of data and you kind of know
exactly what you're gonna get out of it
now that's got me through CS 322 just
fine a few years ago the world's changed
and we've got a slightly more robust and
capable engine in in bigquery that can
represent a lot more than just rows and
columns so a lot of these things are
things like key value pairs there are
things like records or objects there are
things like a raise of objects or
records or key value pairs or all those
things and all of that gets a little
involved so you have to really
understand your schema if you're gonna
be able to make use of a big table like
this so this is the schema that we we
generate as part of analytics from
firebase and and the thing here we're
gonna go through a few of these a lot of
these things we really don't care about
today and you can kind of ignore the
parts you don't you that you're not
using at the moment but we're gonna
focus on it on a couple of these so
right off the bat there's a couple key
value pairs that are really important
there's things like the date and the
timestamp and also the event name every
event that the you that the developers
emits in their firebase app gets its own
unique kind of schema here and we always
key off the event name to say what kind
of
event are we looking at afterwards
there's a bunch of event parameters this
is a an array you can throw in as many
things you want here and in those
there's a name for the for the key so
that says for example here we're looking
at the final score when your level is
done and that's gonna have an int value
associated with it just to make these
easier to use we throw in like four
different values only one of those is
ever gonna be non null every single
final score will always be using the int
and all the others are going to be null
and with something like the level name
we'd be using the string value and all
the others would be null so this makes
it very predictable from event to event
but the actual values that are filled in
you're gonna have to kind of know your
schema for your own events that you're
generating in your in your app and this
is where you your own app can specialize
and and generate the kind of events that
you care about so we also have a user ID
this is something that the app can set
if they choose to and and we also
generated a pseudo ID for the user the
pseudo ID is unique to that user for one
run of the app on one device so this is
what we use to tie in a bunch of events
together to say that they're from the
same run of that app and this is the one
that we're keying in all the time the
user ID again it's optional if you use
that or not in in our sample data we've
actually nulled all of those out because
we don't want any PIAA i leaking out in
our in our demos so we have a slightly
sanitized sudana mised version of the
data that we're gonna be working with
there's also a bunch of user properties
that get associated with that row in the
day in the database and and the the nice
thing about throwing the user properties
here is that those properties change a
lot over the run of an app and this way
you can see what the properties were at
the moment that that particular event
fired and that makes it really easy to
have complex things like the experience
level which for this user is gonna
change basically every time there's an
event there XP is going to be slightly
different at that point so it lets you
see at that moment in time what the
values were we also have whether they're
a premium player or not
all of this data is is up to the app
developer to decide what they want to
stow into this we also track a bunch of
useful metrics firebase supports a lot
of different devices and a lot of
different platforms so it'll let you
track down where the users are what
devices they're using where they came
from
[Music]
which exact version of your app they're
using if you're doing a/b testing that
would also show up there the platform
that you're running on all of this kind
of goes into the app itself and so every
app that you write is gonna have its own
unique concerns about what the user is
up to or what it's doing and these are
the kind of things that you're gonna
want to ask questions about so here's a
here's an example of the bingo blast
game it's a game that's out in the App
Store you can run it and play it it's
actually kind of fun but we we use that
to demonstrate some of the capabilities
of firebase it happens to spit out a
couple of events so every time you
finish around in bingo blast we create a
round completed event and we tie in a
bunch of things like the score whether
the game was solo or a social game the
type of game that you're playing we also
keep track the user data down at the
bottom is whether or not this user
happens to be signed in right now and if
they are we want to know whether they
have ever spent money on the game
because at the end of the day that's a
very interesting metric to be looking at
we also keep track of things like XP
which is really a measure of how long
they've been playing the game and and
and how experienced you'd expect them to
be so with all of that background I'm
gonna turn it back over to Chad and ask
him to walk you through how to use this
kind of data thanks Eugene the next
section of the talk is we're gonna go
through a series of questions I think
back to the deck please we're gonna do
questions at the end oh and I'll say
will remind you this when you do
questions come up and use the mic but
we'll do them all at the end so speaking
of questions we're gonna go through a
few these are the questions we're going
to do we'll start we'll do them in order
these are these are crafted in such a
way as to like literally I run us into a
problem and then show
how to fix the problem run us into a new
problem but we we've played oh and all
of the the code for all of these is in
the github repo and the link to that
repo will be at the end of the talk but
to to save a little bit of time for
Philippe a section on augmenting data
studio templates we're gonna take
question for about filtering by a range
of properties and question 7 about
closed funnels and we're just gonna
leave them for whoever wants to play
with that in the github repo the codes
already there and what we're gonna do is
we're going to do number 8 customizing
data studio template and we're gonna do
that with question number 5 so like the
bulk of the talk is just running through
this henceforth okey doke now let's
switch to the demo okeydoke so here is
the bigquery UI and what we're gonna do
is we're gonna run through a series of
queries to get to the answer to question
number number one so for those not
familiar with it this is the query
composition let me just do a eyesight
check so for the folks in the back of
the room is this big enough I can make
it bigger would anybody like this larger
ok no hands what will will go with this
so anyway so this is where the this is
where you compose the queries I've run
all of these in advance so the results
are already here but what I want to show
with this one so select star also this
is a great thing to do for
demonstrations I don't recommend
selecting all the columns right big
queries a columnar store just pick the
ones you want
because select star queries can get
expensive so not a best practice just an
example for the talk and so when you've
run this query you can see that we've
got an event right here
and then I'll show you how that nested
and repeated field right and so here's
the the country the device and all the
way out here you can start to see that
in this row there are a bunch of these
other nested and repeated fields alright
so how do you start selecting these
things
okey doke so first off we're going to do
like just a simple where we're going to
select round completed okay so down here
on the query window
let's see I have to some reason it's not
showing me oh there we go some reason
it's not showing me the scrollbar if it
showed it was showing me the see if I
can get that to refresh well if it was
showing me up there it is
alright so so event I like here the
basic parameters here
here's round and completed but then
still we've got all the events like the
possible event keys and you can see that
right this round completed there is you
know data here for bingos claimed and
then further out I won't bother
scrolling out here but well I guess I
will further out here we've got the user
events so that's still like the result
here is still a nested and repeated
field so what we want to do is write
let's just pick out all of the event or
the event params where the key is equal
to score right we want to find out like
the goal of this question is like what
are the scores and let's do some stats
on this on the scores that people are
playing and you can tell right we're
getting getting an error here so why are
we getting an error here right one of
the event parameters is score but the
problem is event params is an array so
you can't you have to do something to
event params first all right so let's go
ahead and switch back to the slides and
we'll walk through what you have to do
with event params to get there can we
switch back to the slides please
alrighty
so here's event params and right here's
the problem with there's no there's no
dot key property it's part of this so we
have to extract that first and so
unnecessary code unless that's like a
cross join for those of you who are like
table minded unless you want to find all
the starships where crew member equals
Zoe so if you do it like this this is
what we just did in the bigquery UI if
you want to do this you're going to get
an error so you got to unnecessarily did
in the very first query and
if you cross join if you wrote this out
right this would actually work but you
know so this will actually produce this
table where you blow out you create a
new row for every member of the event
params with crew names and then you can
filter on that by picking the crew
member that you want but they're simpler
syntax to do that where you can just use
this unless command again all of this
code is in the github repo so feel free
to take pictures but you have access to
it at the end and now you can filter on
the parameter you want right so instead
of just doing this filter on crew member
as that first like in that first layer
of query unnecessary
into a table with on nest and then you
filter the way you like ah there we go
and who would have thought that Zoey
likes wing spans of 32 point for
whatever the units are okay so in the
context of our example here we want to
do the same thing right we want to pick
the score per am so unnecessarily want
okay so oh and then here one thing I
should say if you select if you select
star here you're gonna get the event
params array in your answer and that can
just make your answer a little bit messy
like a little larger than you need so
there's a neat tip here where you select
star except for the event params and you
just cut that out up to you
I thought that was a cool trick alright
let's go back to the demo and we'll
we'll get to we'll get to where we want
to go so here's that same command here's
that same command where we unnecessary
the params alright so here it is so
unnecessary have it okay so that's
pretty cool so that's how you that's how
you deal with the the top levers
kima but remember the goal was we want
to do something with these numbers so
we'll go ahead and select instead of
just the event pram we're going to
select the like instead of select star
we'll pull out the stuff that we
actually want and as as Eugene showed
you right we'll just pull out the int
value for score since that's the one
that's not null for this parameter okay
cool and then we can actually do some
arithmetic on it right in the select so
here we have so we're calculating the
average of the int value and we're
calculating the standard deviation and
then returning those so I mean you as
analysts on a game you can then run this
back to your game developers and say you
know hey the standard deviation is way
too high I don't know maybe that
translates to a bad user experience in
some way but this is data that you can
start to use to see you know see
whatever you want to see any case let us
now let's see what the message here is
ah we're gonna go ahead and start number
two let's go ahead and switch back to
the slide please cool all right so
finish number one on to number two with
how does the score correlate with the
user's experience level okay back to the
demo please okeydoke so starting with
the same query that we had before right
this is exactly the same one we want to
correlate this with music's experience
so we're gonna have so member so the
event parameters and the user
experiences we're in two different
member from what Eugene was talking
about those are in two different two
different nests inside a single row so
we're gonna have two unnecessary right
or sorry that second array I should say
ah well boy like not clairvoyance right
I I just I just managed to get that
right so here we go we're in unless you
sir properties and then you can see that
that blows out or just increases the the
scope of the table so the answers
include the user properties as well as
the event properties again filtered by
score
so I'm saving myself the trouble of
running every query here live but now
how do we correlate between the two all
right so next step is go ahead and
filter by the user property that you
want so we wanted to correlate score
with experience points so we'll go ahead
and filter those out so we get the table
so for round completed events here's the
score here's the user experience points
and all right yeah this this step oh
yeah we should point out so almost all
of the user the user parameters come
back as strings so before we actually do
some computation on it we have to cast
the string as an int and call that
experience points and here is the
beginning of the next one so sorry
here's the beginning of the next trick
we'll go through this one and a little
bit of detail in just a second but I'll
introduce it here so in that last query
right we selected event name and then
the the params as the score then we cast
the experience points into intent so
we've got all the data that we want here
but now you have to calculate the
correlation between the two and a for
those of you who aren't sequel or who
aren't born speaking sequel like me a
very clever way to do that and for those
sorry the other the other problem with
this construct in sequel is it's kind of
counterintuitive if you've learned
another programming language first and
so what this is called as a sub select
so what I've highlighted here is the
query that generated the table that we
wanted and then you can take that inside
a sequel query and write a query on top
of it which is this top row here and
then do operations on the result of the
sub query so that's kind of cool we'll
go through that in a little bit of
detail but here's the correlation
between experience points and score so
you can see that folks with a lot of
experience have a slightly positive
correlation to better scores I don't
know bingo is mostly random but if you
get the hang of it you're better than
random I guess that's what that says so
for those of you who gamble on bingo
beware its that was a joke everyone
thank you all right let's go back to the
let's go back to the demo I'll just keep
up the next period sorry go back to the
slides and we'll and we'll go through
what the sub selects are so yeah
correlation of score with experience sub
queries make life easier so here we'll
go through it so we have the schema for
Google analytic in for firebase
analytics inside a big query and then
you do some operation on it right that
was the that query that where we pulled
out the parameters that we wanted where
we did the uh nesting to turn it into a
table and we get the table that we want
now we want to do an operation on this
in the example this was doing the
correlation between experience points
and score so that's we want to turn that
into this other table and we do that
with a query that goes around the
outside of that first one so here I'll
just get to this story so here's a long
one we're not going to go through this
one in detail but the way you've read
queries in sequel is not the way you
read Python or like in my case MATLAB or
C or C sharp right where you define
stuff at the top of the file and then
you kind of go down in sequel you start
here kind of at the bottom like you read
from the middle out right so that's the
base query that's going into the table
in our case like pulling out a none
nesting stuff and then you operate on
that with the query that's above it and
then you know your final query you're
doing a little bit of you know counting
and then grouping by but like realizing
that this is how sequel work was a total
watershed moment for me and so hopefully
that's helpful for the folks who are
like deeply steeped in writing games but
not so steeped in writing sequel very
very helpful toric all righty
so here we'll go back to the code to
finish number two actually never we
already we already finished number two
let's go back to the slides and we'll
move on all right so we covered the
correlation next one is how do we break
out score by game type all right so
switching back to the demo so you would
think this one would be super easy right
we just figured out this on nest uh nest
is
yeah you know uh nest works beautifully
when you've got a when you've got you
have to two different nests in the same
row but if you're but this problem is or
sorry this question is actually going to
run us into a problem where game-type is
actually stored in a different row so
we'll have to see how we deal with that
one so here is here is the way to do it
so in a sub-query in this line we're
going to go into our event params table
and pull out and pull out all of the
event crams where the key equals score
and right so that's kind of that's kind
of what we did in the previous example
and now since we need game-type we have
to go we have to unnecessary this will
go through this in a second in the in
the demo but when you so here we pull
out event name we unnecessarily big
table and then we can also like we can
clean this up again give these give
these some names to make the sequel a
lot readable by the way these aliases
super useful to make your sequel
readable it's fun like as a product
manager working on bigquery I work with
people who are literally born speaking
sequel and so they don't do stuff like
this because this all makes sense to
them and then they send me a query in
like hey Chad what do you think of this
Graham like I can't tell so if you want
your code readable do do that that's a
good thing and so and so here we're
using the sub-select so in this how many
lines of code 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 lines of
code we're doing for sorry 3 sub selects
and one select so you can tell this
trick of using sub selects is really
really prevalent so select from one nest
to get the score select from unnecessary
select from our nest to get the type of
game and that is all excellent executed
inside this sub query
and then we're filtering to get the
round completed and then in the
outermost query we're doing the math and
getting the average score for the game
type and so here down here like here's
here's the result right so we see and
again this is the this is the thing you
take back to the developer team if
you're on the analyst team you say look
folks are doing much better in the
social game than they are in the solo
game is that what we want is that the
good thing or is that the bad thing but
having this detail you know it's good if
especially if that causes you to make a
change or to double down on a behavior
that you like all right
makes sense cool again all the code is
in github so you can like sit with that
as as much as you like all right we'll
go ahead and switch back to the slides
please let me just let me just get this
window set up for the next one all right
cool so select from unnecessary works so
here we are so selecting event name from
you know the events table from this big
table and you see that the gold bricks
here represent the different key values
in the array so we'll go ahead and
unnecessary go all right so we unless
the key and then we're gonna we're gonna
filter that and just pick out the where
key equals score there we go and that
will right that'll put in a score column
and expand our table so again turning
the nested array into a table and then
we're gonna do that again all right now
we're going to go in and get the type of
game so still going into the event
params and this one we're gonna pull out
type of game and that adds a column over
here and now this is kind of like a
regular table like I find this one much
easier to hold in my head conceptually
and then you and then applying you know
filters where event name equals round
completed or where the game type
Beautiful's whatever like that kind of
operation in sequel is far more
intuitive to me so once
get through this part like once you get
everything into this this kind of
tabular format then operating on it I
think gets a lot easier all right we'll
go back to the demo actually to be
honest I think we finished this part of
the demo already so why don't we stay on
the slides please yep so we finished
breaking out the score by game type
we're gonna skip over for Felipe's gonna
do five so now we are going to like
literally cut right to the money and
we're gonna do an analysis to figure out
like what are the patterns that end with
spending virtual currency right since
since this is what makes the world go
around in some circles okey doke now we
go back thanks alright okay let me go
ahead and maximize this so that
everybody can see a bit easier okay
so again with the select star just to
show you what the report sorry what the
result looks like and we're looking for
event names with the event to spend
virtual currency here we go that filter
works and then like as you see out here
like event params has a bunch in the
array so let's start let's start working
with that so even if you want to just
like take a quick look you can you know
pulling out event names user pseudo ID
and time stamp and then ordering by
pseudo ID and time stamp you can start
to get a look at like what the you know
what the things worth at a particular
pseudo you are a user pseudo ID went
ahead and did right because we're
ordering by timestamp right they
initialize the API session start logging
in the problem with this is that I can't
I can't quite show is is that you can
actually get some mixed results when
when people or different people are
interacting with the game so you got to
be a little bit clever here alright so
let's go back to the slides we're going
to introduce another topic calling lead
or called using lead to peek ahead so
this is a trick that we're going to
employ in the demo in just a couple
minutes
so what we
do here right because we're trying to
identify like in the demo we're going to
identify these strings of events so the
user did this then you user did that
user did this and this is this is
paramount to like looking ahead a little
bit in the database so with with our
friends but actually I with the
exception of Mortimer this kind of looks
like names from like a pop band
I don't know Mortimer maybe Mortimer
could be a good pop band name any case
we're going to take we're going to take
this and we're going to figure out how
we look at the next age so this the
command to do that is lead by name so
we're going to look ahead by one space
over order by age so we're going to
order this table by age and then look
ahead one space so in memory bigquery
creates this other table where it's
ordered by there we go where it's
ordered by aged and then you can see
that as we look at Mortimer the next
oldest person in this list is summer so
that's going to be the answer to our
question like what's the next one
looking ahead in the database and then
we assign that we can create a whole new
column here as next oldest so let's go
back and see how that fits into our
construct of doing this work in the in
our example here so whoops
so here we go so we have lead over so
we're going to order by pseudo ID and
event timestamp and so you can see here
that so when the event name is like
initialize the API
looking ahead like looking at the next
event for that user ordered by timestamp
you can see that the next event is
session starts so you can actually start
to get a look at a funnel for this
particular user ID right but that's not
like we don't want to look at what you
know Bob Jane Sally Phil whatever what
that person did we want to look in
aggregate and see what our users are
doing and which one is the most popular
funnel or most popular through our game
that ends in spend virtual currency
right make sense all right
here's another trick by the way
including this partition by command
guarantees that the segments of the
table you're looking at are partitioned
on the user pseudo ID if you don't put
that you're not guaranteed to get all
the block of user well that ends in BA 5
you're not guaranteed to get all of them
together in one chunk all right very
useful tip I'm sure that's gonna save
somebody like one all-nighter of
heartache right there that's that's a
good deed for the day everyone well done
well done
okeydoke so we're gonna peek ahead oh
yeah and sorry you know a funnel is not
super useful if it just has one step in
it so we're gonna look at the event name
right eventually we're gonna you look at
that event name that ends in spend
virtual currency and we'll look ahead
one spot and we'll call that one
you know s1 and then we'll look ahead
one other spot we'll call that one s2 so
we'll get this nice little triplet of
they did this they did this and then
BOOM that ended with spend virtual
currency so here we are here's where we
introduced the filter that defines the
end point for our funnel and that that
starts to generate these cool little
triplets they log in they spun some
slots spend virtual currency so that's
cool right now we know a whole bunch of
trips but the question now becomes well
that's you know great Chad we now have
like how many results like we now have
1000 here down here at the bottom we now
have 1,050 seven different things that
ended up with spend virtual currency
which one is the most important well
fortunately with the tricks that we
learned before we can figure that one
out here let me expand the let me expand
this a little bit so what we're going to
do is we take that same query that we
had before and we're going to wrap it
you know we're gonna make it a sub query
I'm going to wrap it in a larger one
where we select the elements that we
want we count the ones and then this
code down here goes with the outer query
right because it's outside see because
it's outside of the parentheses we're
order by count descending so here we go
so here's the most popular or the most
often used
trajectory that ensign spend virtual
currently currency goes with select
content and round completed Oh round
completed that's interesting when they
complete around they're more apt to
spend virtual currency there's a bit of
interesting information that you know
now you can create these funnels and
figure out where the places that we need
to invest or maybe you look at this and
you're like oh you know what I really
shop page viewed I'd really rather this
be the funnel that that drives the most
value what do we need to do to our
design to push that one higher up on the
list okay let's go back to the slides
real quick so we did that everybody gets
a check mark for number six well done
everyone like you've accomplished
something today and now we are gonna
kick it right over to Felipe who's going
to show you how to take one of these
queries and customize the dashboard with
it so over tea over to you sir
Thank You Todd hey I'm loud now Thank
You table how are you doing so far good
yes I left her a gene I tried to be
quick because I love speaking I'm a
developer advocate but today you have
the chance to ask questions to my
favorite product managers so please get
your questions ready and who is familiar
with data studio good good good good
are you using data studio with firebase
already okay let me show you so we've
been writing a lot of queries just for
the ones that don't know data studio I
want to connect it to bigquery and show
you how to extend it to with the quartz
we've been running so if you look for
the firebase data studio report template
you will find this page and this will
point you to straight to the template
and the template is pretty nice it's
connected to sample data set you can
play with it you can run your filters
you can vision someone already figured
out interesting visualizations to do
with existing data - world events
conversions now this doesn't have my
data so if I want to pull connected to
my data set
query I just need to click use template
and instead of connecting it to the
existing data source I can create a new
data source where I choose bigquery I
choose my billing project I choose my
where my data is and then I get the
template that I can edit and change in
any way that I want and I'm getting
visual results I can share this with my
team I can let my team filter by
whatever they want
let's get only Android results perfect
this goes on the background to be query
and filter things so let's look at
events and here I can search for any
event name this post score for example
and I can only look at those events and
whatever name I want where the score for
example is wherever I want and this is
pretty cool now I don't need to write a
sequel queries anymore except that there
are many things that I can not solve
that with just with a interactive report
sometimes I want to write smarter
queries more complex queries and we can
get back to require for that so if I get
back to bigquery one of the cool things
you will notice that as that estudio is
running queries on bigquery on your
behalf you get to see all the queries
that there is to this running so I can
open the queries here and I can let me
format this query you can see the
queries that darris to this writing you
can use these to ride your own queries
even better than that you can figure out
sometimes how they and nests are done
now in this case in that estudia could
not filter for two different properties
so I brought my own query and here I'm
looking for three things I'm looking for
an event I only want to look at the
event name when the round is completed
and I want to be able to look at the
score to filter out if people are
spending money or not
how many powers they have and I can run
the query here and these are my results
like when the round is completed my
first result
I had a score of 4000 this person did
not spend any money and this person had
these many powers and my next challenge
here is that I want to group this I want
to count again I want to get my averages
grouping by in suspender is pretty easy
like just group is a spender or not but
how do I differentiate it if I have
people that use a lot of powers or
people that are not using a lot of
powers first you'll notice that I've
Chad show you earlier I'm running my own
nest not at the from level I'm not doing
joins between the nest I'm just doing
these mini selects at the select level
where I go through these properties and
I just choose the ones I want and then
with these lines that I will uncomment
here I'm getting the average score I
want to know what the what score are
people getting oh I would be right click
that I don't know so I'm here getting
the average score I'm getting the
variable if they're spending or not and
I'm differentiating between people that
have a lot of powers or not we then if
sentence if they have less than 20
powers it's few powers if they have more
than that as many powers and I will be
able to group by those vials so let's
see our people here let me run the query
here I have my results this is the
average score for people that are not
offenders and / are they using few
powers or many powers and these results
are hard to understand because I have
the numbers here but it would really
would be really nice if I could
visualize them and now in the new
bigquery UI we have this handy button
exploring data studio
and whatever queries I'm running I can
bring back to data studio and just start
visualizing my results so let me do a
scatter chart here and let me get on the
x side I will get the average score let
me even have another column here I just
won't account this is my count of how
many people I have in every block
because yeah I have my four groups but I
don't have enough data of like it would
be nice to see that we have how many
people we have in each group let me go
back to exploring data studio again I'm
getting my results here I'm going to
going to do a scatter chart on X I want
to give the count of people and why I
want to get the average score and to
make it easy to differentiate between
between people that have the news a lot
of powers or not I can add that
dimension here so now I have my four
different groups visualize now I can
even style this to get these people in a
different color depending on if they are
spenders or not let's do it like this
and now my results make sense like who's
getting the highest average score people
that have spent money so it's good to
spend money and that views many powers
even then people that have spent money
and don't have many but only have few
powers you can visualize here get lower
scores and people that are not spenders
and have a situation now this is a
pretty visualization and I want to use
it in my larger dashboard you can just
save this you can do let me wait until
they save its
now I can export the report to an
existing report the one we just created
here I will edit it I will create a new
page because every page is super full of
date already and here I can just control
paste my new visualization and that's
how simple is to go from data studio to
bigquery create your queries visualize
them and paste it in your new reports I
I think it's pretty pretty powerful and
then the rest of your team can come here
use it and they don't need to learn
anything about how to query bigquery we
just do this for them two important
concepts here is that in this report
every time someone is changes one
variable filters by different features
and that's going back to bigquery that
is taking time the takes time cost and
if you have a lot of people looking at
this your cost could go up there are two
things that you should do one is when
you're using bigquery please set up your
cost controls we have a nice feature
cell that will limit how much you are
spending you won't wake up to any
surprise and also there's a lot of
tricks to make the spend use when you
recent data studio to grow almost to
zero I made a presentation about that
two days ago it's already on YouTube
look for it on youtube or on my Twitter
account at Felipe Hoffa
you
[Music]